Have you guys seen the Fortnite competition? The guy won $3 million.
That's cool.
I don't even think about that. When somebody tells me something like that,
it goes out of my brain and then I got to do whatever I do, but I wrote it down.
Cause I was like, maybe I should talk about it, but.
I don't know, man.
Games, right? Video games are surprisingly fun to watch though.
I don't know why I used to have a F uh, my buddy,
my friend used to say nothing's more boring than watching
someone play video games. And I totally disagree with him.
Some guy,
one fortnight the competition and made $3 million.
And he's like 20, he's like 2016. He's 16 years old.
And there was a guy that was 24. That was repping for the old. He was like,
I'm repping for the old guys. And he's 24.
Bro.
Fortnite world cup was a kid's paradise. It says here, this kid won $3 million.
Wow.
Fortnite player, Kyle booga gut guy gears.
Dorf won the world cup solo finals world cup the
19 year, sorry.
The 16 year old North America East player finished with 59 points and
take some, a prize with 3 million.
Cool.
The second place finisher one, $1.8 million.
These guys, his names, you know, booga.
Som Epic whale.
Creo.
Dude. Even the 10th place winner one, $225,000.
Whatever.
Fat, you know, Nate is the worst one with a Y in it. You,
what do you all rapper in the nineties, Nate?
One half a million DJ quick, one, three,
and then red man. And Keith Murray.
Remember Keith Murray, dude, that guy, I love Keith Murray.
Cause everyone else was like making names. And he was just like,
honestly going to be my name. DJ Quik,
Q U I K and all that. And DJ and Keith Murray was like,
all good. I'll just be the guy I am.
Hello.
Love Keith Marie. Love all love. All love. Rap is the only,
you don't want to think. Hertz rap.
Rap is the only, uh, genre of music where there's.
Old school. Why do you label it that,
you know what I mean?
If you didn't label it that then the guys who were old school would still
the could still be relevant. But the second you say they're old school.
It makes them not relevant anymore. Like, I'm sorry, but Eric sermon
rips. A lot of you, young guys don't know what the that is.
Like if you play Fortnite, you probably don't know who Eric sermon is,
but he rips like,
I guess Jay Z would be old school, but he's, he's still kinda,
he still makes music that kind of rips, I guess,
jump out like yeah. Who the you wit
jumped out? Like yeah. Who the you wit? Um, yeah, so
I don't know if, uh, yeah. Video games, I guess,
are going to start building stadiums for video games, which is, which is wild.
You know, think about like the actual
people in the stadium, watching the Fortnite world cup. I would,
I would argue there's never been a more,
a bigger group of unathletic people in a stadium
than in that moment. These guys just like, well, you know,
I think FACHE honestly, you know, I mean, he's, he's number 10, but you know,
he could move up a few seeds. Fats is looking good.
Nate is looking good. Um, you know,
honestly I get booga could take it away, but you know,
it's like 1.8 million for a second place. That's not too shabby. Like, you know,
that's the thing like, Oh, you know,
if I played video games and someone was like, Oh, you're a dork. I'd be like,
you, God right. I am, you are. Right. I am
named Colin is the.
Somebody wrote me on Instagram about my tattoo.
And he was like, your tattoo sucks. This and that. Or I don't, you know,
I remember exactly what he said. He said, you don't get it on your hand.
The first tattoo trying too hard. And I was like,
Oh yeah. It was like,
that's I guess you're trying to keep 16 year old girls liking you or something.
And I was like, why are you so concerned? You know, I had to do a clap back.
I had to send him to Denny's is all good. But he ordered, you know,
he sat down at Denny's sorry, at the grand summer. And I said,
why are you so concerned with 16 year old girls? You pedophile. I said,
also you're fat. Cause I looked at his profile and he was hefty.
And he said, Oh, so you're just going to name, call bro.
You don't get to do that, man.
You walked in this Denny's, this is what we serve.
You don't, you don't know, uh.
Uh.
You know, but you want it to,
I can't help it,
that you can't go back in time and erase the beginnings of that.
But you can't.
Dude, are you.
Do you have a phone booth that goes back in time that sprays purple and green
missed. If you do then go ahead and try to delete that.
But you can't because those don't exist yet.
So why is your nose facing my nose?
Well, what am I ever talking about?